La vida es caos, el universo entero es caos.
Ya sea el terrible estado de mi oficina o
la degradación lenta de mi cuerpo en polvo,
el universo tiende hacia el desorden. Pero,
¿por qué?, ¿por qué el universo está estructurado
de esta forma tan terrible y caótica? Bueno,
resulta que en realidad no es culpa del
universo. Si lo piensas, hay sólo una forma,
o en el mejor de los casos tal vez unas cuantas
formas, para que las cosas se arreglen de manera
organizada. Pero hay un número casi infinito
de formas para acomodar esas mismas cosas. Las
reglas simples de la probabilidad dictan que
es mucho más probable para las cosas, ya sean
las cosas de mi escritorio o las partículas
y la energía que forman mi ser, estar en uno
de los muchos estados desorganizados que en uno
de los pocos estados organizados. Es matemática
simple y es inevitable, es tan inevitable que,
de hecho, nuestra Segunda ley de la termodinámica
dice "Cualquier proceso espontáneo aumenta el
desorden o la aleatoriedad del universo". Los
procesos que no aumentan el desorden del universo
requieren trabajar en oposición al desorden,
y son a menudo imposibles de lograr. La acción
misma de poner un sistema en orden requiere que
otros sistemas se desordenen. Piénsalo de esta
manera: tu almuerzo se compone de un conjunto
extremadamente ordenado de moléculas y te da la
energía para limpiar tu casa, para que puedas
hacerlo tiene que descomponerse en moléculas menos
ordenadas de nutrientes, carbohidratos, proteínas
y lípidos. Estas moléculas se descomponen todavía
más hasta convertirse en energía en tus células,
después tu cuerpo usa parte de esa energía para
activar tus músculos cuando limpias la casa,
pero mucha de esa energía se utiliza para
hacer cosas como mantener tu corazón latiendo,
respirar, sudar, y algo también se pierde en
el ambiente en forma de movimiento aleatorio o,
lo más importante, calor. En el momento en el que
terminas de limpiar tu casa tal vez esté ordenada,
pero los restos de las moléculas de tu almuerzo
están por todos lados. Y éste es sólo uno de los
muchos sistemas que se volvió menos ordenado
mientras tú trabajabas, así que, de hecho,
limpiar tu casa aumenta el desorden general
del universo. La siguiente vez que alguien
te moleste por el estado de tu casa le puedes
explicar esto. Obviamente el desorden es un
gran problema en el universo, y eso genera
un gran problema en la Química, así que
los científicos tienen un nombre especial para
esto: entropía. La entropía es la medida de la
aleatoriedad o desorden molecular. A pesar de que
las personas se quejan del desorden en sus vidas,
no todo son malas noticias. La entropía ayuda a
que las reacciones químicas ocurran y nos ayuda
a predecir cuánto trabajo útil se puede extraer
de una reacción. Todos tenemos que vivir con el
desorden, así que deberías entenderlo bien. En los
siguientes 10 minutos, quiero que aceptes el caos.
¿A qué se refiere la Segunda ley de
la termodinámica cuando nos dice que
cualquier proceso espontáneo aumenta el desorden
del universo? Espontáneo simplemente es un proceso
que no necesita energía externa para continuar, y
también funciona de la manera inversa: cualquier
cosa que aumenta el desorden del universo, ocurre
de manera espontánea. Pero esto no significa que
siempre ocurrirán cosas desordenadas, es decir,
otros factores pueden interferir. Por ejemplo,
la reacción para cambiar un diamante en grafito
sería termodinámicamente espontánea, no sería
forzada por alguna energía externa; pero los
enlaces en el diamante son tan estables que esta
reacción nunca comienza. Muchas otras reacciones
químicas también son así, entonces, aunque a
veces pensamos que espontáneo es repentino e
impulsivo, como hacerte un piercing en los labios,
en Química espontáneo no te dice qué tan rápido
sucede algo, sólo significa que una reacción es
termodinámicamente capaz de ocurrir sin energía
externa. Aunque, ahora que lo pienso, me imagino
que los piercings espontáneos también provocan
bastante desorden, sobre todo al llegar a casa.
La entropía es otra función de estado, no depende
de la vía que el sistema tomó para alcanzar a su
estado actual. Aunque no podemos medir la entropía
de los reactantes o de los productos directamente,
podemos calcularla. También podemos calcular
el cambio en la entropía que ocurre durante una
reacción, de la misma manera que calculamos el
cambio en la entalpía: restando la suma de los
valores de los reactantes de la suma de los
valores de los productos, en otras palabras,
las fórmulas son exactamente iguales, sólo hay que
sustituir HF por S, que por alguna razón se usa
para denotar la entropía. Observa que quitamos las
deltas en el lado derecho de la fórmula, ya que
conocemos los valores absolutos para la entropía
de los reactantes y productos individuales,
mantenemos la delta del lado izquierdo porque
estamos calculando el cambio en la entropía que
ocurre cuando los reactantes se reordenan en
productos. Y, bueno, ¿para qué es bueno esto?
Bueno podemos explicar una cosa misteriosa, que es
como las reacciones ocurren de manera espontánea
en la naturaleza a pesar de que no se emite
energía o incluso absorben calor del entorno y
parece que suben una escalera energética en lugar
de bajarla. Probémoslo con una reacción de verdad.
Aquí en mi escritorio está una de mis favoritas,
este es hidróxido de bario octahidratado y esto es
cloruro de amonio. Normalmente hacemos reacciones
químicas en soluciones acuosas, porque la mayoría
de los sólidos no interactúan fácilmente; pero
este par es la excepción a la regla, reaccionan
enseguida en su forma sólida, pero esta reacción
absorbe mucha energía del ambiente, hace que todo
lo que está a su alrededor se sienta frío. Ahora,
para mostrarte qué tan frío se pone, voy a hacer
algo aquí, sólo tendrás que suponer que entiendes
lo que estoy haciendo. ¿Qué estoy haciendo? ¿Qué
pasa aquí? ¿Por qué estoy haciendo esto? Esto
es extraño, Hank, ¿por qué estás haciendo eso?
Y luego voy a poner esto aquí. Entonces tengo
mi hidróxido de bario dentro de este vaso de
precipitado, y ahora voy a verter dentro el
cloruro de amonio. Uno de los subproductos
de esta reacción es el amoniaco, así que tendré
que oler esto, pero tú no, o sí. Observa esta
consistencia, creo que la reacción está casi
completa, y sí, las cosas salieron bien, y sí,
esto es genial. Absorbió bastante calor fuera del
bloque de madera para congelar el agua entre él y
el vaso de precipitado. En el mundo de la Química,
una reacción que ocurre espontáneamente y aún así
absorbe calor, es realmente rara. Básicamente me
cuesta creer lo que acabo de hacer. Entonces, ¿qué
tiene que ver la entropía con este espectáculo de
fenómenos? Puedes pensar que tiene algo que ver
con absorber el calor del ambiente para enfriar el
sistema. Si bien esto es contradictorio y genial,
no es todo, también puedes pensar que tiene que
ver con los dos sólidos que se combinan para
formar un montón de líquidos y gases, y esta es
una gran parte, pero aún no todo. Para entender
lo que acabamos de ver un poco mejor, necesitamos
poner todo junto. Empecemos encontrando cuánto
calor absorbió exactamente y también lo que
sucedió con la entropía. Primero encontraremos
el cambio en la entalpía usando la ley de Hess
y la centalpías de formación estándar. Podemos
usar los coeficientes de la ecuación química
balanceada para encontrar el número de moles
de cada sustancia, después tenemos que buscar un
montón de números. Recuerda que podemos encontrar
una tabla como esta en la red o probablemente
en la parte de atrás de tu libro de texto de
Química. Y cuando sustituimos las entalpías
de formación estándar en la fórmula y hacemos
los cálculos encontramos que el cambio en la
entalpía estándar es de 166 KJ. Es positivo,
lo cual tiene mucho sentido, ya que la reacción
absorbe la energía térmica, para crear cerca de
medio kilogramo de hielo tendría que estar rodeada
de agua en lugar de aire y dedos. Después tenemos
el cambio y la entropía. Recuerda: la ecuación
básica es la misma. Ponemos el número de moles
de la ecuación química balanceada y también
los valores de entropía estándar de una tabla,
y un cálculo rápido nos dice que el cambio en
la entropía estándar es 594 J/K. Un resultado
positivo significa que la entropía de la reacción
aumentó, lo que significa que los productos son
más desordenados que los reactantes. Observa que
la entalpía estándar está dada en kilo-jules,
mientras que la entropía estándar está dada en
Jules por Kelvin. Las unidades de energía deben de
ser las mismas, así que llamémosle a esta entropía
estándar 0.594 KJ/K. No parece mucho por ahora,
pero espera, hay más. Esos números no explican
por qué sucede la reacción de manera espontánea,
a pesar de que recoge todo ese calor que estaba
en el medioambiente. Josiah Willard Gibbs encontró
la forma de explicarlo, y ni siquiera pretendía
hacerlo. Gibbs estaba interesado en la cantidad
de energía disponible o libre en un sistema para
hacer un trabajo útil. A esto le llamamos energía
libre de Gibbs o energía libre estándar o
simplemente la energía libre del sistema.
Al igual que la entalpía y que la entropía, la
energía libre de Gibbs es una función de estado,
por lo tanto, se puede calcular de la misma
forma, simplemente sustituimos ∆H OS por ∆G,
que denota la energía libre de Gibbs. La energía
libre estándar de formación escrita así es el
cambio de la energía libre que ocurre cuando
una sustancia se forma desde sus elementos en
un estado estándar, es análogo a la entalpía
estándar de formación que usamos para calcular
el cambio en la entalpía. Como en la entalpía
y la entropía no podemos medir directamente el
cambio de la energía libre de toda la reacción,
entonces los científicos crearon una línea base
estableciendo el cambio en la energía libre
estándar de la formación de un elemento en
su forma más estable en un estado estándar hasta
0. El cambio en la energía libre estándar de la
formación de un compuesto es sólo la diferencia
entre la energía libre estándar y la línea base.
Pero ¿y si no conoces las energías libres
estándar de formación para los productos
y reactantes? Bueno, frecuentemente aparecen en
tablas, pero a veces los que necesitas no están
disponibles. No temas, Willard Gibbs tiene una
aplicación para eso. En realidad es una fórmula,
pero él la descubrió. En 1873, Gibbs descubrió
que a presión y temperatura constantes el cambio
en la energía libre de Gibbs para una reacción
es igual al cambio en la entalpía estándar menos
el producto de la temperatura por el cambio en la
entropía estándar. En otras palabras, la cantidad
de energía libre que una reacción hace disponible
para realizar trabajo depende de dos y sólo dos
cosas: el cambio en la entalpía, es decir, la
cantidad de calor que la reacción transfiere,
y el cambio en la entropía, la cantidad de
desorden que crea a una temperatura dada. ¿Qué
es más importante: la transferencia de calor
o el desorden? Bueno depende. Un gran cambio
en la entalpía puede determinar la dirección
del cambio en la energía libre, incluso si la
entropía cambia en dirección opuesta y viceversa,
si el valor absoluto del cambio en la entalpía es
mayor que el valor absoluto del producto de la
temperatura por el cambio en la entropía, o T∆S,
entonces decimos que la reacción es gobernada
por la entalpía. Esto significa que el flujo de
la energía térmica provee la mayoría de la energía
libre de la reacción. Por otra parte, si el valor
absoluto de T∆S es mayor que el valor absoluto del
cambio en la entalpía, decimos que la reacción es
gobernada por la entropía, lo que significa que
el incremento del desorden provee la mayoría de
la energía libre de la reacción. ¿De qué tipo es
la reacción del hidróxido de bario? Bueno, voy a
decir que la temperatura aquí es cercana a los
25°C o 298.15 Kelvin. Esto puedo decirlo porque
así de increíble soy. Cuando lo multiplicamos eso
por el cambio en la entropía que calculamos: 0.594
KJ/K, obtenemos un valor de 177 KJ. Si comparamos
el cambio en la entalpía que calculamos, 166 KJ,
es claro que T∆S es mayor que ∆H, entonces la
reacción es gobernada por la entropía. Ninguna
sorpresa hasta aquí, incluso aunque la reacción
absorbe mucha energía térmica, este fenómeno fue
eclipsado por los aumentos en la entropía, y eso
tiene sentido porque la ecuación balanceada va de
3 moles totales de sólido, cuyas moléculas están
fijas en un sitio, a 1 mol de sólido y 10 moles
de líquido y 2 moles de gas. Éste es un incremento
masivo en el desorden, ya que, además del hecho de
que ahora se moverán 13 moles de partículas
en lugar de sólo 3, el líquido y el gas son
bastante buenos para moverse a su alrededor, así
que la mayoría de estas partículas estarán en un
movimiento aleatorio, ya no estarán ancladas
en un punto, lo que causa un gran aumento en
el desorden o en la entropía. Pero la mejor parte
es que la fórmula de Gibbs también nos dice si la
reacción es espontánea o no. Sabemos que todos los
sistemas tienden hacia el estado de energía más
bajo posible, ya sea una pelota rodando hacia
abajo en una colina o una liga elástica que
vuelve a su forma o iones positivos y negativos
formando un enlace. ∆G es un tipo de energía,
obviamente, así que espontáneamente se aproxima
al menor nivel posible. Entonces, si el valor
para ∆G es negativo, es decir, si la energía
libre disminuye, la reacción es espontánea,
las reacciones que son capaces de liberar energía
libre no necesitan energía externa para suceder,
y ésta es la definición misma de una
reacción espontánea. Si ∆G es positiva,
la reacción no es espontánea, pero la reacción
inversa es espontánea. Si ∆G es 0, la reacción
está en un estado de equilibrio y ningún cambio
perceptible sucede en ninguna dirección. Entonces,
¿qué pasa con la reacción que acabo de hacer?, ¿es
espontáneo a temperatura ambiente?, ¿puede ocurrir
sin energía que le impulse? Bueno, sí, porque ya
vimos cómo sucedió. Pero hagamos las matemáticas.
Usando la fórmula de Gibbs y sustituyendo los
números que calculamos hasta ahora, podemos
ver que la energía libre de Gibbs para esta
reacción es -11 KJ, es, en efecto, espontánea,
ya que libera energía en lugar de requerirla para
comenzar. La energía que se produjo se utilizó
para reordenar los enlaces y los reactantes, para
hacer un producto con moléculas más pequeñas,
para romper la atracción entre las moléculas y
para separar algunas de las partículas de forma
sólida a líquida o gaseosa, lo que aumenta la
entropía del sistema. Entonces, aunque la reacción
absorbió mucha energía térmica no necesita esa
energía para suceder, ya que el gran cambio
únicamente en la entropía fue suficiente para
mantener las cosas en movimiento. Por lo tanto,
la fórmula de Gibbs confirma nuestros resultados
anteriores con sólo una pequeña resta.